hi everyone and welcome back to another
video today i thought i'd make something
that i haven't done for a while on the
channel and that is a more of a personal
video that's unscripted and sharing a
bit more of my thoughts so i'm going to
do a bit of a q a answering some of the
common questions that i've seen popping
up in the comments
but i also asked my patreon supporters
for some questions i've written a few of
those down in my notebook here so i'll
work through those as well as generally
sharing what i've been up to i'm going
to start with the question that i've
used for the title of this video and it
was a comment that i received that asked
me if i had ever failed a test i've
looked through plenty of tests now on
the channel so it's only a natural kind
of question and apart from maybe my real
analysis midterm i do have one
interesting story about failing tests
but it's not probably the kind of test
that you would expect so one test that
made me cry as a teenager was the new
zealand full license driving test i took
this when i was 16 and a half and as the
title says i failed it twice on my third
try though i did pass so i have my full
license now but it wasn't without at
least a little bit of misery along the
way in new zealand you have three tests
before you get your driver's license one
is a theory exam that i got a hundred
percent on the second one is a one hour
driving test where you do all sorts of
things like three-point turns and
various maneuvers that i also aced i got
100
but the third test is the full license
test where it's only a 20-minute drive
and you go through a bunch of hazard
detection things and
general assessment of your driving the
first time taking the test i did really
well for the whole time hadn't done
anything wrong and we were driving back
to the testing facility to go over
everything and just on the last little
corner before getting to the destination
i got done for going over the speed
limit i was going probably between 55
and 60 when the speed limit was 50 there
and i just can't even explain that it
was so out of character for me because
i'm actually a really slow driver and
anyone that knows me would complain that
i drive too slow so to have failed for
going too fast is yeah kind of ironic
but um i think that nervous energy of
being in a testing situation just
bubbled over right towards the end there
and i wasn't really thinking straight
you think i might have learned my lesson
though but the second time i took the
test i did it in a different city i did
it in christchurch whereas the first
time i took it in a pretty small town
that didn't even have traffic lights or
multiple lanes or anything so it was a
very different style of driving to
taking it in a city but the second time
i took the test again did really well
for most of the time didn't do anything
wrong until the last intersection just
pulling into the car park
there was a stop sign and i didn't stop
properly at the stop sign something that
of course you have to do again i think i
just didn't deal well with the stress of
being tested and watched while i'm
driving so that was that got to be like
spongebob at boating school for a while
but eventually got it on my third try a
little taste of failure for me this next
question i must have had over a hundred
times now i get it all the time someone
asking me where do you get all those
exam papers from how did you get special
access and sometimes people even shout
at me in all caps with these really
abusive comments saying
why aren't you using gloves to handle
these precious documents something along
those lines so i just wanted to quickly
say in the descriptions of all those
videos where i use original documents
exams things like that i do always link
to the sites where i get them from and i
don't have any special access i don't
have the original copy of einstein's
grades rather i did enough research to
find them on the eth library website
that's the university that einstein had
gone to doing research to find all those
original documents is probably the most
time consuming part of some of my videos
there are documents that i would love to
cover but they just aren't available
online and not being able to travel to
the libraries in europe and look through
the archives
i've never been able to cover those
things so i do really appreciate when
the universities put them on digitized
versions of the archives and everything
that i cover whether it's the exams the
grades or anything else they're always
publicly available when i access them i
just print them out the best i can on my
little home printer and then show them
under the camera one question i should
address is the common one asking if i
have an instagram account the answer is
no i disabled my account quite a while
ago now and haven't really been on
instagram since
for me instagram didn't feel like a
positive place or a way to spend my time
i would get caught mindlessly scrolling
through things and i would often wish
that i had enough willpower to get off
and go read a book or do something else
it's a platform that kind of made me
feel bad about myself
so it felt hypocritical for me to be
posting photos and trying to grab your
attention and try to make you stay on
the app when i myself wish that i was
spending less time there there's also
the general question of what i've been
up to how i've been doing
um i guess for the last two years or so
i've lived a pretty reclusive life but
to be honest that has very little to do
with covert and lockdowns that's just
the way that i live my life anyway and
how i like to be so without having to
travel or any need to remove myself from
this comfort zone i've just been
enjoying living a very quiet existence a
huge amount of my time though has been
spent on my special project called
finding x which is this animated short
film that i've been working on for
probably over a year and a half now it's
been really a massive undertaking it all
started when i applied for a grant from
youtube and screen australia and you
know i pitched something fairly
ambitious this 10 minutes stop motion
animation all about mathematics at the
time i had never even done any
stop-motion animation but i thought yeah
i could learn that but pretty quickly i
realized i'm gonna need some people who
know a lot more about this than i do and
so i found some amazing people to help
me with the animation with the
production the music the sound the story
and i'm really excited that this project
is nearly finished and i'm hoping to
release it by the end of january looking
at the 25th of january to put it up on
my channel
and it will represent really you know
over a year of my life that i've poured
into this pretty much everything that
you'll see in the film is handmade from
felt so here's what some of that looks
like there are little houses that our
characters live in including our main
character x who lives in this house here
x themself came from this bit of felt
here which i've painted with watercolors
to give it that coloring our other
characters include numbers
symbols
and roman numerals all complete with
their own unique accessories hats
glasses hair pieces a small piece like
the scarf might only get seen for a
split second in the final video
but it still took a lot of work to make
this here is a little chalkboard that i
made for a fairground scene
and these two windows are some of my
favorite assets i modeled them off the
four color theorem especially the
example given on the wikipedia page the
four color theorem states that you'll
never need any more than four colors to
color in the regions of any map like
this such that no two adjacent regions
have the same color
so i had to make sure when i was cutting
out all of these pieces that no two
regions of the same color were touching
and it was a little tricky but i think i
managed to do it right in the end so
whenever i had any spare time i would be
sitting on the floor cutting things out
gluing them together the felt was then
photographed and some scenes have
elements of real stop-motion but for
everything else the images got sent off
to ben who brought them to life on the
computer i've made a website for finding
eggs to share things like the trailer
and behind the scenes and i made it
using xyro who have kindly sponsored
this video
xyro is a powerful and super affordable
web builder which is incredibly easy to
use you can create a website in a manner
of minutes and their pricing starts from
less than two dollars a month with a 30
day money back guarantee and 24 7
support this website i was able to set
up really quickly i started by picking
one of their hundreds of templates and
added the images videos and text that i
wanted
the grid editor makes it easy to line
things up and xyro automatically adapts
the website for mobile view
there's a promotion on at the moment to
celebrate the new year and new projects
so to get an exclusive discount plus a
custom domain and four months free with
any yearly plan use my code tibi's or
click on the link down in the
description they're really worth
considering if you also have a project
that you want to easily share with
people the next question i wanted to
answer is one that asked me to share a
bit about my creative process making
videos and i think this makes sense to
talk about after having shared the
progress of finding x with you
because i have a lot of thoughts about
maybe my philosophy when it comes to
content creation
and you know even a bit of confusion
there on what really is the best
approach always a motto that i really
liked is one that my mum says which is
minimum effort maximum gain
and it kind of sounds a little bit rude
almost but i think it's kind of true
especially with youtube
social media and growth on these sorts
of platforms it seems more important to
be putting out a lot of content that
isn't quite perfect rather than taking
ages to upload real masterpieces
and this is what you see with my regular
content with my normal videos they're
far from perfect they're often just made
entirely by myself and there are so many
aspects that in hindsight could be a
little better but
really if i think about it what would
the payoff be in terms of getting any
extra views if i spent
you know many extra hours on transitions
or fancy sound and things like that i
kind of for the most part think nah
don't go too fancy just put it up and
people are there for the core message
anyway and me investing all that extra
time probably won't result in many more
views or or that much more enjoyment so
then why have i spent a year and a half
painstakingly slaving over this finding
x project it is perfectionism to the
level that every single thing that you
see in it has been through multiple sets
of edits has passed through multiple
eyes and had multiple opinions on if
it's the very best thing for that
particular spot and i really lived and
breathed every aspect of this project
for so long now given that there are
multiple people involved in it as well i
feel like i can't release any version of
it that is less than perfect it's been a
lot of stress to do and i'm not
convinced that after all of that that it
would perform any better than any other
regular video on my channel for most
videos on youtube i don't believe that
there is any correlation between effort
and success as measured in views i know
that my most viewed video is definitely
the one that had the least effort put
into it
and even some of my ones in the top 10
most viewed you know they're kind of
ones that i didn't expect to do well i
just took off maybe thanks to the
statistics of if you put out a lot of
stuff at least maybe something is bound
to be good i won't be upset if finding x
gets less views than say this q a it's
possible um but that's not really what
finding x is about it's not a project
that i undertook to get max views i
think there are many different roads i
could have taken if that was the goal i
think finding eggs is something that i'm
always going to be proud of i think it
looks really beautiful i think it's an
approach to sharing math to people in a
way that i haven't really seen before
and i really hope that you enjoy it too
in terms of my creative process for the
rest of my videos it starts off with
quite a time-consuming phase of research
where i really like to live in the topic
for at least a few days i read
everything about it that i can maybe go
off on a tangent watching documentaries
about the topic on youtube
really soak up all the knowledge about
whether it's a certain country their
exams or a certain character from
history
and then i try to condense that into a
script i only ever really script the
face cam sections of those videos
usually that's the intro for anything
that's overhead i feel like i can
breathe a sigh of relief and just talk
off the top of my head in those sections
because i know
don't have to worry about looking at the
camera looking good or saying sentences
without too many cuts and things like
that i can really just drop all of the
knowledge i know and it doesn't matter
if it comes out in a scrambled way i can
deal with editing it together to be a
succinct story later to do that editing
probably takes me about a day to a day
and a half depending on how intensely
i'm working on it i do the editing
myself on my laptop using final cut pro
and i still use my canon g7x as my main
camera
it's probably one of the least
professional cameras to use for
something like this especially as my
channel grows but sometimes i joke that
i don't want people to see me in 4k
especially if i have you know a pimple
or a bad hair day or something i don't
want people to be able to zoom too close
into that i'm still trying to keep to
that motto of keeping things as simple
as possible and my fairly minimal setup
for these videos seem to have worked
alright so far with only a few
complaints here or there one of the
questions i got was three years later
are you still at peace with your
decision to quit the phd and the answer
to that is yes i'm still pretty happy
that i left my phd and i don't regret it
yet having been three years now a lot of
my friends that i was doing phds with at
the time have now graduated or are
graduating right now and are looking for
maybe post docs or other jobs so i do
feel that feeling of oh if i had stayed
i would have been graduating now and i'd
be a doctor now and i could be going out
and doing those things too but
especially with it having just been new
years i always write out my goals around
that time my goals for the year and
things like that
and you know i've noticed none of them
actually include anything that has a
requirement for a phd so yeah i still
don't feel like it's something that i
needed for the things i want to do and i
feel endlessly lucky and grateful to
have my audience on youtube which i
often think is a little bit more
powerful anyway and i still get really
cool opportunities coming my way next
week i've got a video coming out which
is a collaboration that i did with ibm
about quantum computing and i love doing
that that was like a dream thing to be
able to work on having said that i'm
still so fascinated with many questions
in science and i don't think i can ever
leave that curiosity behind and that's
what attracted me to the phd in the
first place it was never about the
credential it was about the experience
and who you become getting that
opportunity to do research
if anything i don't have plans to return
to a phd program anytime soon but i have
this pipe dream of maybe approaching a
local uni and asking if i can work with
them as sort of you know a research
assistant for a few months or something
and just being able to have a taste of
that research environment again and
maybe pick and choose a few different
topics i'm interested in i still don't
think i'd be able to stick to one niche
topic for the three or four years that
it takes of a phd up next we have the
mildly requested bookshelf tour this is
just what i've got on here at the moment
here i've got my newton's principia copy
that i have used in a few videos
fun fact i bought this online and i
didn't like the cover that it originally
came with so i printed off this original
cover and then stuck it on with like
transparent book tape this one looks
like a stolen math book from school but
it's actually not at least i didn't
steal it my mum loves going to op shops
and she sometimes gets me books as like
a present which is really nice of her
but she knows i'm interested in
something to do with maths and physics
so if there's ever a book that has maths
in the title she'll probably bring it
home for me this one she got me from the
op shop recently it is the journal of
the korean mathematical society it's
literally a bunch of printed out really
abstract math papers from some july 2017
conference
these are some more second hand books
this one i got it's from oops upside
down
the ambidextrous universe by martin
gardner
a story about galileo's daughter that
would probably make for a good video one
day
these marcus chown books are pretty
important to me because i bought these
when i was in high school with some book
vouchers that i won at school they're
probably some of the first physics
ebooks that i ever really read this one
here fred watson's star craving mad fred
is an australian astronomer and science
communicator and he was working at the
australian astronomical observatory in
sydney when i was an intern there so i
got to meet him and spend some time with
him and so this book is actually signed
dear toby from one astronomy
communicator to another with very best
wishes for a sensational astronomical
career all the best fred it's funny to
read this because at the time he wrote
this i wasn't even making videos on
youtube this has got nothing to do with
my youtube channel he just knew i was
involved with some in-person science
communication i've got a mathematical
nature walk contact by carl sagan
alice in wonderland
a little book of string theory of which
i have some bookmarks in that show you i
never made it all the way to the end
i've got this little book in here which
i have a poem published in from school
i might as well show you these library
books i've got out here now too this is
written by george gammel mr tompkins in
wonderland
dedicated to lewis carroll and niels
ball i haven't read it yet so i don't
have too much to say after making my
recent video about kepler's insomniam or
the dream i actually found a copy of it
in the library surprisingly enough kind
of wish i'd found this earlier instead
of having to just read everything off
the computer for the most part when i
look at my bookshelf i think uh i wish i
could read more i'm such a slow reader i
don't know if it's good or bad i try and
say that's good because at least i stop
to think about things you know between
every few pages but it also means i
barely ever get anything finished
this here is a little lunch box that i
actually got from educon
when i went to america back in 2019
they got someone to spray paint all of
our channel names onto these lunchboxes
which i think is so cute and so
thoughtful so
it deserves a little spot on the shelf
ichikon was probably the best event i've
ever been to because i got to meet some
of the creators who i've looked up to
for so long who are nothing but kind and
willing to help even the smallest
creators sometimes i think the highlight
of my youtube career is having been able
to mix with them on something like equal
terms
last point of business is a hair update
because this never otherwise makes it
into frame in fact it's pretty hard to
get it in now
but yes i do have absurdly long hair
no i haven't had a haircut for probably
10 years
and yeah it's probably
just down to my knees at the moment or
just passed
but there you go that's a hair update
thanks for watching this video and
thanks to my patreon supporters a
special shout out to today's patreon dog
of the day yoyo
you